what do you do when somebody beats you
to market I'm going to answer that
question in today's episode of lunch and
earn so Risa got asked a question from a
good friend of mine that I haven't
gotten back to in a while really sorry
to Lush tell ash wrote in to say hey
Evan I've been working on a project
that's been something I enjoy and also
really needed by my community for the
past few months unfortunately never put
as much time or effort into it as i
would like that is currently a secondary
project i also have possibly a problem
pursuing perfect instead of good as a
result others in my fields who have also
identified the need for what i'm working
on recently beat me to the punch and
launched a very similar project with an
extremely similar name only days before
i finally got my act together i am too
disheartened to continue or even go
through with my lunch right now how do i
make this work talash caleche I really
feel for your man when I first read this
i actually thought you said you couldn't
go through with your lunch instead of
your launch and i was stressing out that
you were eating so i'm glad that you are
and i have three bits of advice that i
think will help you number one
understand that opportunities are like
trains if some get derailed there's a
new train always coming along a my field
I could think of tons of ideas in
different ways that I can help
entrepreneurs and I'm sure the more you
get involved in your industry in your
field you'll find others so if one
doesn't work out that's okay you don't
want to get so disheartened and so down
on yourself that you stop doing
everything new right a new train is
coming along there's always a new
opportunity just keep looking for ways
to help out your customers number two is
you have to be passionate about it
honestly honestly is like some harsh
truth my feeling is if you were spending
months and just making slow progress on
this and it was a side thing for you you
didn't really have the passion to turn
it into something bigger right when I'm
excited about something I'm up until
three in the morning trying to find ways
I'm thinking about on my weekends right
that a side project is just a hobby and
it's something you do every now and then
fine whatever but it's not something
that you are obsessed with right when I
when I was obsessed with snowboarding I
would find ways to put off meetings and
not go to the office and
not get work done so I can go
snowboarding right it was like it was a
huge passion of mine when you're in
relationship and you're in love with
someone you find ways to help them and
do nice things to them and surprise them
things that might not make total sense
and you put other things off to go out
and accomplish it and so the same thing
happens in business when you love what
you're doing you find ways to get it
done you stay up late you do extra
research when you're having showers and
playing with your friends you're
thinking about other ideas you can do to
make this idea work better you just were
passionate about it and so I honestly
wouldn't worry that much about losing
this idea to somebody else because I
would rather you focus on something that
you are really excited about something
that makes you come alive and something
that you are willing to put other things
aside forth to focus on and that that
idea that train is coming number three
is out execute them having the idea and
being first to market is usually not the
game it's much more about can you
execute and be better than them so who
cares if they got the product out there
first right if you love this thing so
much and you're potentially the best in
the world I created this just out
execute them make it better when I've
made these videos on YouTube are not the
first guy to make videos on YouTube I
had an idea that's different I love it
and I am just out executing other
channels and that's why we're getting
thousands and thousands more subscribers
than they are so if you love the idea
and you know that this is a train that
you want to be on just focus on out
executing your competition because the
only real competition is this guy so I
hope that helped to lash good luck keep
me posted and I promise you I won't take
months to get back to you this time when
you're right back and for those you
watching I'd love to know how you have
handled that situation I'd love to know
what you think about somebody else being
first to market and how you reacted to
it leave it in the comments below i'm
really curious to find out i'm in the
journey the discussion so thank you so
much for watching continue to believe
and i'll see you soon